Um, and let's go next to our caller from the
eight 62 area code.
Who's calling today from eight, six two.
Oh yes.
Hello? Yes, that's you.
Oh my God.
Really?
Yes.
And we're not on speaker phone, right?
Uh, no, it's the connection.
Spell that.
Oh, and it just sounds a little echo.
What's your name?
Hi, I'm a child from New Jersey.
Sorry, what was your name?
Ciao.
Okay.
Short for Chelsea.
All right.
What's on your mind today?
Okay.
Um, I have, um, I have one, uh, an observation
that I just kind of want your take on.
Okay.
Um, I feel like, uh, I am like a progressive
in general.
Like, I don't even know, like I, I'm a Bernie
Sanders ordinary supported in the 2016 and
I'm, I'm supporting him now, but I try to
see like, I want Marianne Williamson to come
in and give us all some political therapy
because I don't know, I like this we anger
and like really talked to the city.
Then I feel like a lot of the presses on them
caters.
I like kind of avoiding discussing like what
the root cause of it as.
And I, I'm trying to decide whether it's like
the hatred that people have for who he crazy.
So strong or is it like a love for Bernie
Sanders that is causing like so much chaos?
I don't know if you would've thought I owe
like,
right.
Well listen, I definitely notice anger in
the political world.
I think a lot of the anger is warranted because
we've had ideologues and corporations and
their lobbyists basically take over and control
every aspect of life and you know, rape and
pillage the lower and middle classes, uh,
for their benefits.
So like I get the anger, we look at other
countries that are as rich as ours, and we
see that they have things that for whatever
reason we're told we can't have at the expense
of having this completely overinflated military.
Uh, so I get the anger.
I think that what you're pointing out where
I would agree is that there is a degree of
toxic infighting on the left.
And I've talked about about it myself, where
if you're not on 100%, uh, with the people
who set the litmus test, you're sort of thrown
out as if you're not even a valid person on
the side that we're all on.
And I think that that is the problem on the
left that I would most identify these, these
kind of, you know, if you're not with us on
everything, you're, you're, you might as well
be against us.
I'm sniffing.
Yeah, I'm sniffing.
I mean, you know, the left person's right
thing, if some are going, going to happen.
But I'm specifically talking about fighting
among progressive.
Yeah.
You know, I see it in, in, in politics, in
politics to wake up the whole Russia issue,
which I guess I don't want to get into because
like it, I'm tired of talking about it, thinking
about it.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know.
But there was a lot of infighting around it.
You're right.
Yeah.
I'm there.
There are people that I work with you and
I really respect, I like a lot of attention
from you and see like secondly, coming off
anyway, people I really respected who ignore
one part of the mall for it because they think
that it will somehow validate it.
It'll show me why I'm being more than Sa.
[inaudible] yes.
Rush that did in her hands in some way, you
know?
And then they, they just shame on the part
where, you know, they feel like Trump was
exonerated.
Not because they went from things like his
presidency or what he's doing, but because
they ate chili cookers so much.
Like they don't want to like think about any
other possible reason for her life other than
herself.
But I would marginally agree she lost because
of herself.
I didn't know Kennedy, you know, people who
have put [inaudible] conservative
hello?
You can serve.
Yes.
Okay.
Well, alright, Chow.
I think she said her name was, uh, thank you
for the call.
I agree with you about some of the internal
infighting just being really, really bad.
All right.
That's all the time we have today.
We will take calls again.
Uh, that's it.
We'll go to a break.
Sorry to everybody.
I did not get to